hello got mick or should i say got meek
which i think is what you have to go by
now
no no knock on me trixie doesn't have
that big of an impact
tracy does not have a say
literally trixie has the biggest impact
that she was able to change my name
fully
like like great thank you george and
with got me because like girl that's her
go to her instagram
that is her it's finale day and you've
made it to finale day
what does this day mean to you
it means so much to me to be in the
finale it's just so crazy to see how
you know i grew up being told that i
wasn't allowed to do drag let alone
beyond drag race and now i'm here at
canalia and i could win this like it's
just
such a magical insane feeling to me to
be able to conquer all that and finally
be here she is the wind beneath her own
damn wings well let's talk about the
potential
herstory-making moment history-making
moment
sistery breaking moment of
you potentially becoming the first trans
man to take home this title what would
that mean to you and what do you think
it would mean to the community at large
um
it would mean so much to me obviously if
i was the first trans man to win
rupaul's drag race
for so many reasons i think like i was
just saying
just the fact that for my own personal
level just being able to conquer all
those people and say like you
like can prove all these people wrong
that i am here
and i'm trans and i do drag and i can do
dragon dragon art and not
identity and i just thought to prove
that so i'm so proud that i was able to
come on the show and tell my story time
to crash the system
see how many people were inspired by my
story
and i inspired to start drag and move
forward in their transition and so many
things so i know that even just me being
on the show no matter what happens like
i made such an impact i'm so proud of
being here a little bit i mean yeah
you've
literally changed the game helping to
change the world baby
oh my god
i wrote i'm born a girl and i haven't
talked to these [ __ ] about it
and how you were hesitant at first to
even have to reveal that part of
yourself
to the family that the sisters you would
create here can you talk about why you
were hesitant and
how you overcame that hesitancy i was
just so hesitant
across the board because i wanted to
come in and just be this
good role model and be able to tell my
story from like the
with the perfect words and say the
perfect things
and be like the perfect little gorge
drag queen i could ever be with my
perfect makeup and waist and everything
and then
the more i realized that my drag is so
much more than just this
physical aspect that i thought it was
the more i was able to have fun with
my comedy and my acting and like so many
things i learned that i loved even more
than
my physical appearance now which is so
crazy and
i think when i started opening up and
having fun
in my performances i was like i don't
need to worry
about saying the right thing and being a
perfect role model because just
being visible and being myself is all it
takes
to be a role model and that's why people
are going to connect with me as just me
being myself
and being open and so i just became a
lot easier
and it did not it definitely helped that
every girl in this class is just so
welcoming and open and like
they're like girl loves that moving on
like let's
let's fight for this pound so it was
just such an amazing journey for me in
every aspect of it
the family feeling of this season i feel
is really special and i
i can only imagine part of that is the
covet of it all
and you are in this bubble just with
each other you talk about you know
having to present this perfect comic
this perfect drag queen
but the viewers have also taken to got
mc out of drag
you know the boys the girls they're
crushing on you how are you receiving
that
that is funny um well i'm obsessed with
that
because like i mean even on this is like
a stupid level but
i mean just being able to like look like
that
with my attitude magazine cover like me
two years ago
starting hormones seeing that i would
have been like screaming
so the fact that i made like a magazine
looking like that and people are into it
i'm just dying inside it's still like
new kind of so i'm just like it's just
a dream come true and still looking for
a boyfriend find me out there or
girlfriend whatever it is just
holler at me please okay what are the
the requirements i would imagine fully
vaccinated and then
definitely deaf of acts are a double
dose boxer
um i yeah my requirements are
definitely just have a really gorgeous
personality
and i love a funny [ __ ] and that's
pretty much it
across the board you can find that
i'm like america's like american idol
right now i'm like just
make me laugh well
you you made rupaul laugh i think rupaul
maybe fell in love with you this season
oh my god
watching back all those critiques as
they aired week tweak i mean what was it
like to
take in all that positive feedback from
the queen herself
yeah it was just so unbelievable to me
and we like genuinely had
such amazing chemistry on the show and
it's like that's why
challenges like snatch game and things
like that were just kind of
easy for me and fun for me because all i
had to do was just talk to her
and we get along so well hey roo how's
it going just let me know when the
cameras are rolling and we'll kill it
well we've started the cameras are
rolling
oh that's so embarrassing sorry
i'm so happy to be here all i have to do
is talk with her and then just like
taught my parents so it's
so easy and then it was just i was just
so blessed
to have that and she did an interview
before the
show even started where she was just
saying that like i helped her open her
mind
and like to remind herself to like keep
moving forward and i think
she started this show out of this like
punk rock like let's
make drag me stream and i think i came
up in here and kind of like was like
okay you did it you killed it and let's
push it even farther and open these
doors even more and i feel like
she just vibed with that and saw that in
me and
we just like thought it was amazing well
in the back of my head i'm like
does raven need to be worried about her
job would rue
bring in gottman to do the face oh my
gosh
well the next time raven's sick i'll
volunteer but
but until then she can she can have her
to unpack some of the stuff you said
there one the paris of it all
i loved that you got to facetime with
her and get her
stamp of approval and then i noticed she
put out a music video pickle
and there's an outfit vibe look that's
very similar to what you wore in snatch
game i think you maybe
inspired the woman who inspired you oh
my gosh well
i would die i don't know if she would
ever admit that but i would die and i
love you saying that
um but yeah at paris i was so she was my
first major client i
ever had and so it's kind of the
craziest weirdest full circle moment
ever i remember being like
going to fashion school and getting a
call they're like do you want to give
chris hilton's makeup for this magazine
cover and i like have never had a
magazine cover and never had a celebrity
client i was like
yes and i like full skipped my last
final life to go paint paris hilton and
then i just one snatch game as her so
it's just the weirdest life is so weird
it's like manifesting without trying
without one
well she's in the sex necklace and she
has a pink
like marabou moment happening i don't
need to see this
i'm dying not the sex necklace the sex
necklace it's there
i i feel like something you really
learned about yourself this season is
you're a funny [ __ ]
yes yes i did get to learn that i mean i
always know as funny and like i
have i love my personality and my
my ability to connect with people but i
didn't know i could
write jokes and like have good comedic
timing and all that
like that part of it which is why i was
nervous going into all those comedy
challenges i was like i should be able
to be fine because i like know i can
loosen up and be funny but at the same
time i have to sit here and write jokes
and like deliver them
in front of rupaul on tv so it was just
kind of scary and then when i
started flowing i was like oh my gosh
girl like it is
it's like kind of natural to have that
ease that i have on stage with that so
i was like now that i know how to write
the jokes it's game over for you [ __ ]
hi you guys lonnie love
i just cannot believe i am standing up
here
presenting my comedy in front of you i
knew there was going to be budget cuts
this season but i didn't know it was
going to affect the judges panel too
give me a roast tour i'm ready to go on
it like it's my favorite thing in the
world
and i'm a shady [ __ ] i can read down so
that helps
i was gonna say all these girls need to
brace for impact whenever that tour
happens because i
don't think it'll be pretty but it won't
be pretty oh
yeah oh yeah and i have like a list of
some dolls that i think we would just
rip each other apart it'd be so fun
was learning about your comedic
sensibility and your ability to do that
the biggest aha moment for you in this
competition or was there something else
that you learned about yourself
yeah i think i think it was the aha
moment for me
overall i think was just maybe
almost like rusable time when i just
learned to
let go information laundering fun
photoshop to fool everyone like that was
the first time
that i think the judges saw that i was
like
here to win was around that time because
i was just like letting go and having
fun
and i realized when i was on stage even
no matter what it was like snatch game
gross rusical like if i was having fun
it was translating
period like even if like someone was the
most perfect performer in the world like
i was
in the top with them because i was just
crazy in the corner doing my own thing
having fun and i think that's
really important in drag is to have your
brand and understand what makes you
unique and not try to be anyone else
except for yourself because the second
you're like oh rose spinning like i
better spin
like that's where you're gonna fail
george like
right you have to be yourself no matter
what in this game
i would imagine this finale is going to
look different than the finales we've
seen in the past and i know you probably
can't say too much but give me a word to
describe
what we're gonna see in this finale my
word is definitely artistry
we're jam packing as much artistry as
you could ever jam-pack in an episode
like i
might i can't even comprehend it it's
crazy
i'm ready for it all right i want to
wrap this up with a little bit of rapid
fire about the season
what was your favorite look this season
it can be yours it can be someone else's
oh i think of mine
i think i have like a tie i love my body
bag from ball
that's like the most me outfit ever i
love my little black dress and i love my
pockets look and then my favorite other
look overall i think
is simone's bead look i love that
like she walked out i was like no no no
that's one of my favorite looks
and like drag racing least favorite look
of the season
oh great question i think
honestly honestly honestly i'm not a
huge fan
of um the look elliot went home
in with her flamingo outfit
i just think a nude illusion should be
tight but i mean flops to her she loves
mangoes so she's staying true to herself
like gorge
not my face okay i would rather have
lala's bag outfit honestly on my body
wow that is a statement but i will take
it i like a controversial opinion
um what what was the quote of the season
for you
oh i love an untucked when can't um
tina was talking i don't know what tina
was even saying but candy goes well you
have a natural
comedy face to tina and gina's like
right
yeah okay well you have a natural comedy
face right
like she didn't even pause this one she
said that was so funny that's one of my
favorite moments ever
are you wearing tina's hair right now
got mick i mean i might as well be i
literally
i told my uh wig designer i was like
just surprised me at this point
i literally can do whatever color
whatever style and then this
came and i was like i'm tinabarner i'm
also a halloween
queen right now and like you're giving
me
like pennywise but make it fashion a
hundred
thousand percent like i am the queen of
halloween today for the finale of the
paul's drivers so
hello all right what was the lip sync of
your life
for the season for you my favorite lip
sync
was the bag ball with lala picking up
the money and like
using it
[Music]
it was so good i remember being there
and being like i cannot believe i'm
witnessing this this is so funny i was
obsessed with her
and then any rupologies anything you
want to apologize for as we wrap up this
season
oh my god never i literally could go out
there and lala's bag look and i'd be
like i love
it no i am so proud of everything that i
did on the season
and i have nothing to apologize or
regret
or anything i would not choose a thing
you walk away from
season 13 with a crown or maybe not do
you come back for all-stars
oh wait if i don't win when i come back
for all-stars or if you win i mean oh
oh they're asking winners back i was
like not manifesting that right now
putting that in the universe me not
winning
um i i definitely would come back for
all stars i
genuinely like i said love talking to
rupaul it's so much fun there and
i it is rupaul's drag race was the
ultimate like
boot camp of life for me like
spiritually even
so i was fighting tooth and nails like i
do not want to go home when
the end was wrapping up i was like
[Music]
so i can just imagine if i had a whole
another season to like keep growing and
keep going like
at the end of that season which it would
be getting over
you deserve more than a cop behind the
fabrics.com wall though
well that's just where my bunk will be
that's like where i'll just like stay
and i'll come out through the day
there we go all right well
congratulations i cannot wait to see the
artistry you pull out of this finale
uh it's been so much fun watching you
and getting to know you through my tv
screen so
and i'm excited that the world will
hopefully be open soon after this finale
air so you guys can get out on tour
and make that money i know i'm so
excited to meet everyone and be out
there it's going to be everything
i put in work baby so fight for yourself
and let all the basic haters love baby
that face that sounds so right clown
pain and weight so tight boys girls and
in between
it's time to crown your queen let's go